et
[Musique]
la proche de l'été les affaire
d'intoxication ghb dans les bars n'en
finissent plus depuis un mois des
personnes principalement des femmes
racontent avoir été agressé après avoir
été droguées les témoignages de femmes
victimes d'agressions sexuelles afflué
sur les réseaux sociaux cette semaine
c'est la chanteuse luan qui aurait été
victime de vertiges et de vomissements
alors qu'elle sortait d'un bar dans le
18ème arrondissement de paris
est vite prise en charge par un médecin
les symptômes qu'elle décrit s'apparente
à une consommation de ghb la personne va
être un peu ces dates ernst somnolente
et ne va pas enregistré ce qui se passe
mais que s'est il vraiment passé doit-on
craindre la multiplication des attaques
ou ghb en france ce soit le journaliste
florian anselme et l'addictologue
laurent karila sont avec nous pour en
parler
merci laurent karila d'être avec nous
at-elle un soleil avant qu'on ait
l'histoire qui va nous être racontée par
florian en scène merci jean nice causeur
et amy non bien sûr chroniqueur chez
matthieu delormeau dans tpm people
qu'est ce que c'est que le ghb le jaish
b c'est une drogue c'est une drogue
ecstasy liquide donc c'est lui qui tu
sais quoi c'est propriété florissante
propriétés aphrodisiaques mais aussi
propriété amnésiante c'est à dire que on
peut en prendrait un peu ne plus rien se
rappeler à cesser alors les effets donc
nous avait donné ça dure combien de
temps les effets les effets sont très
très très rapide on en 15 30 minutes ça
arrive ça dure 3 3 heures en moyenne
ouais et après ça se dit si on peut ne
pas s'en souvenir on peut ne pas s'en
souvenir et le problème c'est qu'il faut
les deux est vite fait pour savoir si le
ghb dans le sens où dans les urines ça
qu'on appelle on l'appelle la drogue du
violeur anciens c'est un agent de
soumission chimique en fait c'est comme
l'alcool et bien que des épines en fait
la drogue du viol c'est un truc très
très médiatique la crise que dans les
années 70 des années 90 ont 10 et ouais
c'est la drogue du viol etc mais donc
dans ces agents là au premier plan c'est
l'alcool comment ça se matérialise c'est
ça que j'aimerais ça parce que comme on
dit parfois on se dit oui on ne m'a mis
du ghb dans mon vais axer recommencent à
se matérialisent commencé c'est un
liquide inodore incolore et sans saveur
un peu amer ouais mais il le met dans
les verts déjà où il ya de l'alcool
c'est parce que le ghb il faut pas le
boire tout seul dans un verre en
plastique ça fait fondre les verres en
plastique
ah ouais donc c'est extrêmement violent
et l'échec mais que ça veut dire quoi
les mecs qu'ils ont des petites fioles
c'est des petites fioles d'un mini
litres mais il ya des gens qui
consomment du ghb pendant les fêtes ils
font la fête au ghb pour avoir des
parties sexuelles avaient si on tour
mourir bien sûr on peut faire ce qu'on
appelle des jo le cd coma et on peut en
fait le ghb tout seul peut ne pas tuer
mais il peut tuer mais surtout s'il
souvent mélangées à de l'alcool à des
benzodiazépines et c'est là où il ya des
décès c'était pas avec à l'origine c'est
un décapant pour joe oliver exactement
quand une anecdote avec plaisir j'avais
j'avais je soigne des patients qu'on
éprouve avec le gbl qui a un dérivé du
ghb et un jour à côté à côté de
l'hôpital où je travaille à la maison du
parc etc et une grande maison qui vend
des parcs et le patron m'appelle et me
dit
dr cary la wii voilà on a un problème
toutes les semaines on a les mêmes
personnes qui viennent acheter des
bidons de 5 litres pour leur parquet ils
doivent avoir un parc immense
c'est en fait ils dansent les liquides
pour parquer il ya 8 gb el aouel alors
l1 ça c'est intéressant c'est pas une
anecdote à nous dit non non non je vous
dis quand on te retirer cette drogue
c'est une drogue qui agit qui perd vite
dans le corps donc pour la dépister il
faudrait faire un test sanguin six
heures après avoir moins de six heures
après avoir consommé ou un test dans les
urines moins de douze heures avant le
conseil si les gens ne font pas de son
temps de l'utiliser dans certains
traitements non alors oui on sent que
c'est balèze chat c'est balèze
docteur ouais je sais là
je fais arrêtent leur non non c'est vrai
que je sais laurent tu l'as déjà fait
c'est bon
oui oui il ya le ghb médicale c'est un
traitement médicamenteux qui est testé
pour les problèmes d'alcool notamment ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le ghb se
comporte comme l'alcool et les
tranquillisants comme le lexomil l'homme
je cite des marques comme ça mais je
sais beaucoup de gens dire non mais
laurent c'est extrêmement intéressant ce
qu'il dit parce que on va avoir le récit
de ce qui est arrivé à luan voilà qu'on
adore bien sûr chanteuse actrice voilà
et florian qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
sais que vous avez toutes les infos sur
cette affaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter mais elle est tout
simplement aller boire un verre
tranquillement avec une amie avec avec
la nounou sa fille dans un bar du xviiie
arrondissement parce qu'elle habite
là-bas qu avec son compagnon et sa fille
donc et un peu plus tard en rentrant
chez elle a été prise de vertiges et de
nausées de sensations assez assez
désagréable on va dire elle a appelé son
médecin tout de suite qui est venu et
qui a immédiatement suspecté ce que
décrivait monsieur c'est à dire des
symptômes dus au ghb donc qu'il a il a
ordonné en tout cas il a préconisé car
il faire les tests les tests adéquat
pour pour vérifier s'il s'agissait bien
de ghb ou pas elle a évidemment porté
plainte donc ce qu'il faut faire bah à
l'heure actuelle on n'a pas les
résultats des doutes elle a dû voir
peut-être quelqu'un qui était quelqu'un
qui va demander une photo qui étaient un
peu bizarres ou alors ce qu'il raconte
est en tout cas dans l'article du
parisien qui a qui ont sorti l'info ce
matin c'est que a priori personne ne
s'est approché d'eux que personne
ne les a sollicités et c'est ce qui
était raconté ce matin après peut-être
que depuis d'autres choses c'est à qui
tu es et tu es vraiment mal voilà était
vraiment très très mal après après luan
il faut aussi dire que c'est quelqu'un
alors je je je minimise absolument pas
son état etc elle devait forcément se
sentir prêt vert mais c'est quelqu'un de
très fragile quelqu'un de très fragile
qui est qui a pendant longtemps elles
sont exprimées dans des interviews avait
du mal à sortir à être avec du monde
autour d'elle et c'est quelque chose qui
est elle à lutter contre ça l'a vu un
psy elle voit un psy depuis l'âge de 8
ans quelqu'un qui a perdu ses parents
très jeunes etc c'est quelqu'un de très
très très fragile donc évidemment
peut-être je ne souhaite pas mais
peut-être qu'elle a qu'elle a pris une
substance que kg et qu'elle n'aurait pas
dû mais c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à remettre le
nez dehors pendant très longtemps donc
peut-être que ceci pourrait expliquer
cela en tout cas c'est ce que je lui
souhaite parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'elle n'a pas été aligné le médecin
willie bain dr karl a parlé tout à
l'heure des boîtes de nuit des lieux où
sont souvent administrés les doses de
ghb là ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'on
est un lundi à 19h30 non mais ma barre
serait plus les boîtes de nuit tous les
bars pour savoir comment il ya un truc
il ya un truc important c'est ne jamais
laisser son verso jamais jamais et même
mettre un cac vers si c'est possible
génial ça existe dans les capotes de
verre
au bar café le café standard près de
chez vous vous laissez jamais vos
adversaires jamais votre version
castagné je crois qu'il le laisse jamais
seule ce n'est jamais loin tu en verre
cassé un bar très tranquille fréquenter
plus tôt par des personnes âgées
personne ne les aurait approché donc
c'est extrêmement étonnant là bas on les
a contactés saint marc qui a voulu des
abeilles sont extrêmement énervé parce
que ça peut devenir à l'image du buy
gens qui viennent les jours et si
vraiment on peut se faire administrer du
ghb à lundi à 19h30 dans un marché
extrêmement alors ils disaient 19h31
lorsque la jeune chanteuse s'est rendu
dans un café donc devant martin rue des
abbesses et ce que vous dites dans dix
huitième a été accompagnée de la nounou
de son enfant les deux femmes n'ont vu
qu'un verre et non pas quitter leur
table c'est ce qui s'est dit personne ne
s'est joint à elle très vite loi n'a
commencé à ressentir des symptômes
étranges précise une source policière
vertiges nausées vomissements situation
c'est ça les scellés ouais c'est ce que
vous racontez ces les symptômes par
exemple de canton mais ivre avec
l'alcool voyage avec le ghb ça peut
faire ça encore une fois on n'a pas de
résultats de dosage
mais le ghb se comporte comme l'alcool
et les tranquillisants donc
c'était pas dans un verre d'alcool ce
cas d'abus non même tout comme un verre
d'eau
à potentialiser
vincent bogard on peut faire le
parallèle aussi avec parce qu'il ya une
enquête qui est ouverte depuis le mois
de novembre parce qu'elle est beaucoup
beaucoup de dénonciation affaire de
dénonciation de deux rapports qui
ressemble à celui de luan aujourd'hui
c'est sérieux on peut faire un parallèle
avec les piqûres qui existe aujourd'hui
dans les boîtes de nuit dans tous ces
lieux la turquie dont on entend parler
malheureusement depuis des semaines et
des mois il ya une grosse grosse montée
de ces choses-là des plaintes sur la
plusieurs sexe et l alerte 1 ce soir et
santé moi je suis je vous dire ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a
effrayée c'est qu'elle décide de rentrer
chez elle bonne elle rentre chez elle
difficilement l appeler son médecin et
ce qui est fou c'est qu'il a
immédiatement pensé à une intoxication
au ghb ça veut dire que il envoie ses
courants c'est pas un truc auquel tu
penses tout de suite banon c'est ça qui
est incroyable c'est laurent mais bon
hein mais bon c'est un médecin qui vient
en urgence que c'est au domicile il est
bon quoi non mais c'est à croire ça veut
dire qu'ils envoient mais de toute façon
il faut y penser systématiquement
maintenant c'est un réflexe à avoir en
2022 non mais c'est fou donc cette
drogue est présente et surtout pour les
jeunes faites gaffe faites gaffe
vraiment ça c'est à dire partout ouais
ouais c'est partout c'est quand même
extrêmement philippe c'est le début de
l'été le début de match fut guère flambé
concerne le chauffeur vraiment à le dire
il ya eu plein de bars depuis l'été
dernier un c'était dans les boîtes c'est
vrai que c'est descendu dans les bars il
y avait 60 fait il ya eu neuf plaintes
mais 60 faits dont six hommes donc
effectivement ça touche tout le monde
c'est pour ça que la procureur a ouvert
une enquête et je ne parle pas de ce bar
en particulier mais il ya eu des dents
l'enquète il ya des soupçons sur des
employés de bach c'est à dire qu'il
agirait en duo vous avez une victime
repérée alors c'est plutôt en ce moment
pour dépouiller que pour agresser
sexuellement mais sur les dizaines de
cas mais il agirait à 2 vous avez un
employé encore une fois je parle pas de
ce bar vous avez un employé qui peut
être complice qui administre qui repère
qui administre lui reste à son poste il
a administré la substance et la personne
boit et un complice va suivre la
personne pour la dépouiller donc ils ont
des soupçons de fonctionnement en duo et
y ai eu plein de bars à bruxelles
notamment il ya des associations qui
se sont mobilisées
il ya eu des cas à lille marseille
grenoble nantes paris donc la belgique
il ya plein d'associations qui en ce
moment qu'on danse pour après rapporté à
la pologne pour essayer de voir d'où
viennent les cas donc vous avez raison
de lancer l' alerte c'est extrêmement
préoccupant mais vous avez nommés puis à
aussi le hashtag il ya un hashtag
balance tombe à bahreïn ce ton bar qui a
été qui a été lancée au même moment de
ce que raconte et gilles et surtout ce
qu'il faut je vais revenir sur ce que
disait guillaume genton ce que c'est
très important c'est souvent dans des
bars qui ressemble au bar de monsieur et
madame tout le monde c'est à dire c'est
pas des endroits où on a l'impression
que c'est le temps de la dirno logique
wordpress et des bars brasseries ont le
temps mais tabac c'est la lithologie
excuse moi oui oui c'est vrai enfin
voila c'est des endroits tout à fait
banale où on va acheter des cigarettes
boire un café ou une bière etc le
soupçonne évidemment pas victimes d'un
vrai on se méfie pas et c'est helwan
j'ai encore une fois je le souhaite pas
mais si ça lui est arrivé elle sait
absolument pas méfiée j'aimerais docteur
on est tous égaux face au ghb en fait
comment comme on peut être sûr de
comment va réagir en fait comment il
faut qu est ce qu il faut faire tourner
un doute ben les symptômes c'est des
symptômes comme à l'écrit cyril c'est à
dire on titube on est aussi comme si on
était saoul voilà des symptômes c'est ça
on est comme si on était ivre avec
l'alcool mais plus le dosage est élevé
soumis à des risques de comas secours
aide ménagère deux ados par exemple
elles sont tout le temps en fait flipper
entre les points leur meilleur l'alcool
village mais tout ça donc est ce que je
leur dis c'est quoi ce qu'il faut faire
être entouré je pensais ne jamais rester
ne jamais rester seul d'accord consommer
qu'on se ne jamais consommer seul à
avoir toujours son verre sinon nous
couvrir que le couvrir il ya des choses
dans les bars et sinon il faut s
achètent sur internet etc
il faut plus il faut et c'est sale et
les principaux conseils de départ après
il faut pas mélanger appris l histoire
d'alcool et il faut pas mélanger la
halle collègues d'autres produits parce
que ça les jeunes ils le font un peu il
ya de ces éléments là et là c'est l'été
comme disait valéry c'est là où c'est un
pic dangereux je fais pas une alerte
mais me direz que je dirais que la
soirée estivale arrive assez vertement
j'en ai fait mon temps je veux montrer
le témoignage d'une femme droguée au ghb
vous allez voir elle en a fait les frais
vous allez voir ce témoignage je voulais
absolument vous montrer soit regarde il
est sorti dans la rue et la main quand
je me suis s apparemment mon état s'est
dégradé en 10 15 minutes et
je savais plus où j'étais je savais plus
comment mes amis ça fait et à force et
apparemment je me rappelais même plus de
comment je m'appelais moi même
heureusement claire était avec des amis
qui l'ont raccompagné car le ghb est
aussi appelé drogue du violeur liquide
ou en poudre dans un verre il est
inodore incolore et n'altère pas
l'aspect de la boisson en somme il est
indétectable et provoque une soumission
chimique
voilà tant que lorsque je dis merci oui
j'ai une question c'est la même dose
quelqu'un on va dire qu'il ait 90 kg et
qu'à 20 ans sera sera touché de la même
manière qu'une jeune fille qui ont fait
55 ou n'ont cessé ces variables le poids
peut jouer là d'accord voilà mais c'est
tout petit dosage en fait c'est en
fonction du dosage c'est comme quand on
boit un verre d'alcool certains vont
recevoir devons ressentir des effets
d'ivresse d'autres non ça va être pareil
que des petites doses de ghb et puis on
va augmenter les doses parce que les
gens qui consomment déjà joué consommant
routes ou les deux heures du ghb alors à
0,5 mille idées recettes millilitres ou
un millilitre d'accord oui une question
si par exemple aussi deux copines y en a
une qui se sent pas bien comme ça a été
le cas pour luan que doit faire l'autre
à part une fois qu'elle a appelé la les
médecins ou les pompiers en attendant à
ce qu'il faut la faire boire vu le faire
boire de l'eau à qu'est-ce qu'il faut
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire mais il faut
rester avec elle il faut attendre les
urgences folle être surveillés on peut
le faire boire un peu d'eau mais mais
mais faux viol à surveiller faut pas la
laisser faire alors pas du tout pas du
tout paul simonnot le mieux c'est
d'aller aux urgences si vous nous
rejoignez un sur ces huit louvre luan la
chanteuse et comédienne voilà soupçonne
quelqu'un de l'avoir droguée au ghb dans
un bar parisien et le on nous disait il
ya un instant vraiment que c'était assez
courant que s'il y avait eu des cages et
nous l'a dit de partout en france un
appartement voilà ça devient de plus en
plus courant fait alors de quel est le
but en fait
gilles parce que vous avez dit que
c'était le vol alors tout c'est quoi le
but au départ ça s'appelle la drogue du
violeur mais aujourd'hui on fait prendre
parce qu'effectivement les gens qui en
consomment sont dans un état second qui
ne savent plus où ils sont et il ya
toute une partie qui est purement
délinquante c'est à dire je repère jeu
dépouille j'attends que la personne
sorte et si elle est seule donc
vulnérable je lui vole son portefeuille
je lui vole son sac et s'est énormément
de cas répertoriés donc ça voilà ça se
développe du côté pour détrousser les
gens mais ce qui est inquiétant c'est
qu'apparemment on peut en trouver très
facilement du ghb now fait dont on
achète un bidon de 2
en fait c'est le gbl ça qu'on achète
c'est un dérivé du gel
on peut d'emblée lancé sur internet le
vecteur c'est internet on se demande sur
internet du liquide de freins ou du
nettoyant de jantes ou du nettoyant pour
paquet ah ouais répond c'est pour ça que
c'est important cela en même temps on
dit qu on peut en trouver facilement et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut prévenir les
jeunes qui m'a regardé que le message il
est essentiel comme on peut en trouver
en achetant du liquide de freins
vraiment surveiller vos verres buvait ou
si vous allez aux toilettes vous touchez
pierre votre verre on est dans une de
tarés où il faudra acheter sur internet
un cache pour partir avec son cash dans
la poche pour le mettre sur le verre
haut possible dans les 70 ans on vous
dit la plus liquide de parquet c'est
tellement faut dire aux jeunes c'est
tellement facile d'en avoir que faut
vraiment se protéger contre ça c'est vu
guillaume non effet d'aversion la 10e ou
piqûres parce que la plupart servent des
piqûres sont vides et apparemment c'est
des jeunes qui s'amusent à faire ça
juste pour piquer des gens mais il ya
certains cas où il ya des traces de ghb
qui ont été revus dans les piqûres c'est
pas un seul réseau ces jeunes qui
pillent tout le monde envoie deux
notions dans les festivals dans les
soirées leur administre du ghb donc il
faut faire extrêmement attention et ce
qu'il faut porter plainte
automatiquement les
portes et soumission chimique l'accord
te plains tout de suite voir si
aujourd'hui comporte bien qu'à comme les
piqûres y florian oui non je voulais
revenir aussi sur luan parce que c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un
tu sais c'est quelqu'un de bien enfin
tout le tout les échos qu'on assure
j'adore loi d' c'est vraiment une femme
c'est rare une femme super et le fait
que ça tombe sur elle alors encore une
fois on souhaite qu'ils lui soit rien
arrivé ça c'est terrible c'est quelqu'un
qui est vraiment fragile sur vision la
série dans laquelle elle a joué ya pas
longtemps elle avait un coach qui
l'accompagné au quotidien est suivi par
un psy sa soeur qui fait psycho l'aide
beaucoup elle a été maman elle n'a pas
fait de scène pendant quatre ans elle
est devenue maman pendant le confinement
ça a été à la fois super et en même
temps assez assez compliqué donc si là
elle sort elle se remet à sortir à
revivre sa vie un petit peu il lui
arrive ça c'est vraiment terrible et je
voudrais juste souligner aussi un truc
c'est que moi j'ai appelé un ami qui
travaille dans le milieu de la nuit
juste avant de venir dans l'émission qui
m'a dit il ya quelque chose de nouveau
depuis la fin de la crise sanitaire
c'est qu'en fait les jeunes les gens qui
font la fête ont tellement pas fait la
fête qu'ils ont une insouciance qui est
démesuré par rapport à vent et ils font
ça par rapport à ce qu'on disait encore
moins attention il faut vraiment plus du
tout attention et forcément les styles
vers directement docteur comme on est en
train de parler des alertes avant les
soirées estivales on m'a parlé d'une
nouvelle substance alors là qui serait
sans doute pris sur la base du
volontariat mais je voulais votre avis
parce qu'à des jeunes qui m'ont dit
c'est une substance qui a un goût de
réglisse qui est très dangereuse qui
s'appellerait de 3 mm c'est vous avez
entendu parler de ça on m'a dit que ça
commençait à tourner dans les soirées et
peut-être qu'il faut dire aux jeunes si
on vous propose un bonbon réglisse ou
quelque chose réglisse il faut surtout
pas le projet c'est un goût de réglisse
ou sur le doubs le 3ème mcc la 3éme mcc
une drogue de synthèse d'une nouvelle
route du centre est ce qu'on achète sur
internet en russie voilà et qui se
comportent comme les amphétamines ou la
cocaïne est en fait cette drogue là
était d'abord
plutôt utilisé dans les parties de kembs
ex les parties sexuelles avec des
produits plus tôt dans la communauté des
hommes comme les rapports sexuels avec
des hommes donc ses rangs des parties
sexuelles avec des produits est en fait
ce qui se passe là depuis quelques mois
la 3éme mc et ben monsieur et madame
tout le monde se mettent à consommer de
la croix et même c'est parce que
malheureusement enfin c'est comme la
cocaïne amphétamines mélanger ça coûte
moins cher cher c'est mais ça fait des
dégâts
considérables
c'est à dire aux jeunes si on vous
propose des choses en soirée surtout ne
plus sûres amen accepter rien façon le
message de batz et en soirée oui il faut
pas accepter un produit qu'on connaît
pas de quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas et
c'est ça que c'est quelque chose
d'important et même de quelqu'un qu'on
connaît c'est compliqué dwan est allée
au commissariat afin d'avoir une
réquisition pour une prise de sang et
ainsi détermine de déterminer
intoxication on aura les on peut avoir
les résultats quand il faut qu'elle ait
eu cette prise de sang avant 6h au moins
six heures après lequel les consommer
donc d'accord si elle a eu à cette heure
c'est mort d'accord voilà d'accord donc
donc mes peintures à d'autres substances
voilà si l autre chose qu'à six mois je
vais revenir sur les problèmes
psychologiques qu'elle accepte ça a
l'air d'être des troubles anxieux de ce
que vous racontez je pense que c'est
quelque chose d' indépendants mais ça
peut raviver ces troubles le sait sauf
quand ces gens là ces accords on les a
au bout de combien de temps les
résultats pour savoir vraiment si on a
été ça peut très rapide sur une
réquisition sur un labo qui c'est qui
sait faire ça rapidement il ya des labos
très spécialisés on a les résultats
quasi tout si c'est le cas il va avoir
une enquête huile au laos ah oui c'est
sûr bel et bien agi à la portée de la
maintenant on va voir si ses adjoints à
l'ats l'information judiciaire la
procédure qui avait été ouverte en
novembre 2000 21 ou si c'est indépendant
il y avait beaucoup de cas dans le
quartier de pigalle à paris et c'est pas
très loin donc c'est pour ça que les
policiers se penche sur la sphère
vraiment là d'accord c'est quoi c'est
des gens penser quoi cette saison qui
est un réseau réseau dans les bars il
essaye de voir si l'anc est peut être
unifiée sur paris effectivement il ya eu
énormément de bach et là c'est un bar
aussi donc dans ce quartier là les
marges sont sous surveillance et ça
c'est très bien et encore une fois tout
de suite porté plainte et qu'est ce
qu'on risque et qu'est ce qu'il risquait
alors s'est ouvert pour administration
de substance nuisible
si jamais on démasque est un réseau il
pourrait être condamné à de la prison
ferme parce qu'il ya des gens
effectivement parce que l'état des gens
il ya des gens qui sont extrêmement
malade et qui ont des ddc quel argent
avec l'énergie et comme dit le dr oui ça
peut raviver aussi d un des axes un truc
qu'on avait ça peut
raviver des problèmes psychologiques est
ce que ces deux problèmes distincts
c'est à dire que quand on a un trouble
psychiatrique
préexistants et on prend des drogues
dessus ça peut réveiller le problème
psychiatrique le ghb si par exemple on
le prend dans un verre parce qu'on a été
droguée par quelqu'un on peut avoir des
séquelles après c'est ça alors sur une
consommation on peut faire un les
accidents psychiatrique on peut faire un
accident délirant aux urgences
psychiatriques on peut faire un accident
avec un risque sanitaire on peut avoir
des troubles de mémoire rapport héran
les séquelles c'est plus on répète les
consommations